[Musique]
ont la tête dure quand ils décident de
creuser un trou dans un arbre difficile
de les arrêter mais quand l'arbre est
plutôt un poteau ce sont les
fournisseurs d'électricité qui doivent
se creuser la tête
ces jours d'inspection comme d'autres
équipes sur le terrain d'Anne mastropola
et Simon Lamotte examine l'état de santé
des poteaux
Hydro-Québec gère un parc de près de 2
millions poteaux chacun est inspecté au
moins une fois ou 10 ans ces 200 000
inspections chaque année et parfois ils
ont des petites surprises
j'ai un truc
un trou de sang
les deux ont leur exploratoires
ce que on voit avec les statistiques
qu'on a c'est une croissance dans les
activités des pecs vers nos poteaux on
voit la programmation des dommages
on voit des endroits qui étaient pas
touchés que maintenant devient de plus
en plus toucher
que des pics bois décide de s'attaquer à
des poteaux de distribution plutôt qu'à
des arbres c'est plutôt cocasse mais
pour les compagnies qui assurent les
distribution de l'électricité c'est de
moins en moins drôle
si on regarde les chiffres en 2012 et
2020 et un on a plus que 100000 pourtour
documentés avec des dommages pic bois et
donc à peu près
12 mai sont en remplacés
chez Hydro-Québec les trous des pics
bois représentent la deuxième cause de
remplacement des poteaux la première
c'est l'orage un poteau a une durée de
vie d'environ 60 ans et on a longtemps
cru que les pics bois s'intéressaient
davantage au vieux poteaux après tout
ils sont plus susceptibles d'être
envahies par des fourmis charpentières
le festin des piques mais
erreur
Sébastien tilleman a eu la surprise de
sa vie en 2015 adopté son Ontario c'est
quelque chose qu'on n'avait jamais vécu
avant dans aucun de nos autres projets
bien qu'on en ait eu plusieurs dans dans
des zones forestières une de ces de
distribution flambe en neuve et prise
d'assaut par des pics bois
la centrale est en opération on avait à
peu près une cinquantaine de poteaux
déjà endommagés sur 500 on fait qu'un
10% là de la ligne
aujourd'hui évidemment il y a plus de
poteaux et davantage de paix le relevé
des oiseaux nicheurs au pays indique
qu'entre 1990 et 2014 la population de
grands pic aurait doublé au Canada et
triplés au Québec
qu'est-ce qui fait que s'installe sur un
poteau par rapport à au fait de
s'installer en pleine forêt ça c'est une
question qui est ouverte actuellement et
qu'on veut explorer dans les deux trois
prochaines années et c'est pour ça qu'on
a déployé des équipes de terrain pour
sonder davantage cette question là
pierre de repos travaille depuis plus de
15 ans sur les pics bois son projet de
recherche actuel est réalisé
conjointement avec l'Université du
Québec à Montréal Hydro-Québec et
hydromega
donc on a commencé ça avec le
laboratoire de Pierre drapeau en 2017
pour essayer de déterminer sur nos 500
poteaux lesquels poteaux étaient les
plus à risque et donc de vrais être
protégés en priorité
pierre drapoux et son équipe ont
parcours eu le terrain aux abords des
lignes électriques et en milieu naturel
pour mieux comprendre l'environnement et
le vent il vient des pics bois deux pics
en particulier les intérêts le Grand Pic
et le pic flamboyant c'est quand il
décide de s'attaquer au poteau pour
niché ou se nourrir qu'ils peuvent créer
des dommages plus conséquents
ça c'est un exemple de d'une part de
marque d'alimentation de Grand Pic des
grandes marques rectangulaires comme ça
puis l'oiseau creuse passablement à
l'intérieur du poteau ou de l'arbre
souvent parce que il y a des colonies de
fourmis de fourmis charpente entière
dans l'ordre naturel des choses ce
serait donc les fourmis qui s'installent
en premier malgré les produits qui
couvrent les poteaux pour prévenir la
pourriture elle pourrait peut-être aussi
profiter du réseau de fil pour se
déplacer d'un poteau à l'autre et y
installer des nids satellites cela dit
une fois que les trous d'alimentation
sont creusés par les piques c'est une
porte ouverte pour la pluie les
champignons il a dégradation du bois
mais les plus grands dommages au poteau
c'est quand le pic décide d'y faire son
nid ce segment de poteau était retiré de
la ligne d'hydromega un pic qui avait
construit son nid
on voit on voit que que c'est quand même
un trou qui est imposable si on regarde
le rapport entre la longueur de ma main
et la grandeur du trou
contrairement des trous d'alimentation
qui font environ 2,5 par 10 cm la cavité
de nidification fait environ 25 par 50
cm un trou B1 au cœur du poteau c'est
pour ça que ces poteaux une fois qu'on a
des nids vraiment complétés
là sont vraiment à risque et on est
amené à les remplacer très naturellement
là ça c'est des poteaux donc qui ont
moins de moins de 10 ans et qui doivent
être déjà remplacés comment expliquer
que les pics même quand ils ont accès à
des arbres à proximité choisissent
néanmoins les poteaux pour un pic un
poteau Diderot c'est un chico mort sur
le terrain c'est comme ça qu'il faut le
voir
pour un pic qui à l’œil la taille du
poteau à séduire à une dizaine de mètres
du sol où il est à l'abri des prédateurs
le diamètre du poteau fait souvent une
trentaine de centimètres c'est parfait
pour y creuser un nid est-ce que le fait
que la forêt soit jeune est-ce que le
fait qu'on aille de petits arbres est-ce
que il y aura un manque pour le boulot
ou les rames ferait en sorte que le pic
serait intéressé à utiliser nos poteaux
connaître l'environnement forestier les
essences et l'âge du peuplement près des
lignes électriques pourrait peut-être
fournir des indices
ce que je pourrais avoir une cape une
carte de sensibilité une carte où je
pourrais prédire les endroits où j'ai un
risque il y ait des dommages avec les
piques
au-delà de l'environnement forestier les
comportements des pics doivent être
mieux étudiés leurs habitudes leur rayon
d'alimentation
Philippe leurs activités Unis en milieu
naturel
et il fait plus à l'aide d'une caméra
montée sur une perche il vérifie si le
nid est complété et occupé qu'est-ce
qu'on voit sur le terrain c'est que
c'est très fréquent de trouver des
cavités qui sont débutés mais pas
complétés des fois ils vont ils vont
choisir un site pour faire leur
exclamation il va frapper du bois dur
qui est pas adéquat à l'exclaviculation
de leur cavité puis vont changer de
place ils vont l'abandonner mais ils
peuvent toujours revenir l'année d'après
pour continuer
l'excavation du trou vu du sol c'est
très difficile de savoir si l'excavation
de la cavité a été complétée ou non
et le vérifier chaque fois avec une
perche serait long et embêtant à
proximité des fils électriques si on
avait juste des trous exploratoires il y
a peu d'impact sur la capacité du poteau
mais dès qu'on commence à pénétrer à
l'intérieur et surtout à grandir le tout
pour faire un nid ça commence à faiblir
le poteau
mais comment savoir à partir de quand la
capacité mécanique des poteaux endommagé
par les pics et compromis
sur des clowns numériques des poteaux
avec des cavités de pic bois on estime
d'abord les zones probables de rupture
plus tard sur un banc d'essai on compare
le comportement simulé au comportement
réel du poteau
un treuil tire sur sa tête pour le faire
fléchir jusqu'à ce qu'il cède
les premiers essais montrent des pertes
importantes de capacité selon les
dommages causés par les piques
on a vu une variation en 10 et presque
40% d'apports de capacité donc 40% c'est
assez important en affaires à plus que
40% en théorie on devrait le remplacer
la poteau
pour les compagnies comme Hydro-Québec
ou hydromega remplacer un poteau à un
coût et on ne veut pas le faire
inutilement
si on parle de remplacer le poteau
complet incluant faire les transfert
c'est au tour de 5500 dollars en moyenne
mais qui a des transformateurs sur le
poteau ou sur le montage est plus
complexe ça peut coûter plus cher pour
une compagnie de la taille
d'Hydro-Québec slappeux représenter des
millions de dollars chaque année
[Musique]
l'autre option c'est de tenter de
décourager les pics bois de s'attaquer
au poteau à l'aide de protection
physique des gaines rigides qui
entourent les poteaux des grillages des
enveloppes de caoutchouc les mesures de
l'atténuation sont pas super efficaces
celles actuellement sur lequel on
travaille ce sont des poteaux en
composite
c'est l'option qui a choisi hydro-attawa
en 2017 après qu'une série de photos en
bois sur une de ces lignes aient été
attaquée par des pics bois une solution
radicale et coûteux
c'est sûr que ça coûte plus cher que des
poteaux en bois donc probablement pas
possible de faire ça sur une ligne de
500 poteaux mais peut-être que si grâce
à ce modèle développé par Lucas mais
éventuellement on est capable de
localiser certaines zones qui sont plus
à risque
déterminer les zones passe par une
meilleure compréhension des habitudes et
du comportement des pics bois après tout
les pics bois sont sur leur territoire
et les compagnies de distribution
d'électricité dans d'autres choix que de
composés avec
[Musique]